[Music]
it's all right to tell me what you think
about me i won't try to argue i'll hold
it against you i know that you're
leaving you must have your reasons the
seasons are calling the pictures are
falling down
wow
get out of my room mom all right get out
of my room mom this is the late cast
welcome to it
i stole some beers here at corridor
digital to bring you a podcast because
that's the way we want it to be we want
you to have these podcasts so you can
enjoy them as much as we enjoy making
them so welcome i hope everybody's doing
great is this some weird like texas
outfit uh you know this is what they
wear in texas this is what they wear in
austin maybe
um no we're filming son of a dungeon
right now we're just wrapped day five
and uh man it's going well every frame
of painting
and um not the channel but like it's a
great channel it is at one point um yeah
oh a story on rip later
but yeah uh so we just wrapped day five
and um it was it went great
um so i'm in costume still because we
went right from that to this and yeah
everything looks super good we just
finished the first vfx shot of the
season did you yeah
it's looking good yeah mike seemed like
he's stoked he's like
oh
that's awesome so that was a good
reaction i was like
yeah
shot that's the big opener once
spoilers oh yeah
opener spoilers we have uh
taking painstaking efforts we have took
painstaking efforts this season to try
to bring the quality of everything you
see above and beyond what you saw in the
first season not just the story but also
the
um
the
green screen in world footage um the
level of characters that you see um the
action the sound design the music um
so
yeah we even casey's adding on to the
library from the first uh season all the
music he has his sort of like core and
then he's
adding songs and i love that all that
stuff's on spotify now yeah it's so cool
too because if you like anyone's doing
an instagram post they can just like put
the song in it as well because it's just
on their knowledge so yeah
it makes it real yeah it's great a real
boy so wait who do we have here for the
audio only listeners oh who are you wow
hi i'm matt i'm i work here hi matt yeah
i'm better i also work here oh cool
really congratulations man well thank
you yeah good to have you i'm nick i
don't work here yeah nick we just
brought him up the street yeah yeah he
seems like a nice guy yeah it's cool
guys yeah
yeah
yeah man so uh well who who are you
though oh i'm warren watt uh bard and uh
uh
bard and illustrious um
citizen of cecilton jake's real method
he doesn't yeah great character ever
yeah and um i've been on an adventure
slaying mind flares uh but i walked
through a portal and i ended up here
wow and uh you guys seem seem pretty
cool so i think i'm gonna stick around
if you don't mind cool hell yeah brother
happy to have you brother welcome to the
is this the future well i don't know
actually is this is it or is it a
different dimension yeah probably a
different dimension i don't know
i have a spell called dimension door oh
yeah is that how you got here no
dimension door can only transport you
500 feet to a known a previously known
location
wow
i can't get through dimensions with
dimensions it's not a very cool
dimension i mean it's it saved me one
time there was this man named gorgeous
greg yeah he was a member of the i
remember that guy
shire yeah he had a sick treasure room
gorgeous greg well no gorgeous that that
was uh vinsilius
yeah it happened
yeah it happened at vince
star yeah but gorgeous greg is no longer
with us um unfortunately he turned into
a mind player oh
yes he did yeah wow man was he gorgeous
i have to i have to throw this out there
there's a
life-size replica of no spoilers some
kind of animal in our studio it's a
donkey you can say it's a donkey
spoilers there's a dog
behind you
for the listeners there's a there's in
the frame is this damn donkey oh dude um
jake how much does that donkey cost
well to rent it it costs 237 dollars a
week
that's actually good we're only renting
it for a week for a week okay and to
purchase it costs about 900
oh okay yeah okay so that that's what i
heard i heard that it was like a grand
to rent no well i heard depending on how
long you hold it for okay yeah we should
uh photo scan that sucker then we can
have it walking around
there's a scene in season two where i'm
sitting on it well it's nico casts
spider climb on it yeah which gives it
the ability to walk up and down walls
and then
bob ren's character throws me on top of
it so i'm sitting on this donkey while
it's climbing down a wall
and i'm like trying to stay on this
thing
um have you filmed with it yet
uh
no
no not yet did we film with it yet
randy got a shot okay
okay yeah
it's just very funny to have a
life-sized donkey sitting in our studio
yeah yeah well it's a little bit smaller
it would be a very small donkey it could
be a tiny dog yeah it would be pretty
small at what point do we just buy the
donkey
to have wow
you know i mean
not yet not yet yeah one more week
though maybe she's hit that point yeah
we could have nat cast the donkey and
then we'll just have one yeah
you could hang it from the ceiling
that'd be it come on
it's there when we need it yeah yeah
steve used to have what an airplane
hanging from the ceiling uh it wasn't
steve so the guy that used to have this
law this studio before us was named ben
and he was this um kind of like hair
brained
uh
artist slash
uh engineer
i guess you could call him an engineer
um and he had all these weird and wacky
inventions that he had like hanging from
the ceiling
uh vinci's workshop and he used to have
so well they used to hold raves in here
back in the back in the 90s like late
90s and early 2000s when that was a
thing
and then uh
he used to have a dj come in and
like on fridays and he would just like
have people over
and it was like this vibe
you know
thing yeah
weird
stuff that's going on in the studio oh
they used to shoot pornography at the
end of the stream
yeah joel's old place and
all the girls would be like
god only knows what they were up to in
there but then they'd come out and
they'd be like standing in the street
and like their little
you know was that was when y'all were
here yes
sitting out there smoking cigarettes and
yeah has changed a lot no way
that's wild now we have like weed
businesses nice established businesses
yeah yes this nice the nice established
businesses yeah
and then uh under the bridge there was
this guy named sarco that used to uh
have a truck
yard do you sell potions no
he was this uh i don't know if he was he
was this latino guy and he used to just
like hold pallet parties where they'd
like
make
structures out of pallets
and then they just like it's kind of
awesome they just go for it man they
just burn them no i do whatever you want
out crawl around whatever you want
bridge burning man you should have a
pilot party yeah yeah
they had uh
they had um go-karts and they'd ride
them up and down the road at night
and um what that's weird what happened
to the city dude i know this used to
this area used to be like
you know oh yeah a lawless area yeah the
best because all the manufacturing so
all these buildings were built in
you know like the 20s 30s and 40s
and then when that american
manufacturing like went to the wayside
this area just became desolate
and then all these artists started
moving in here because you had a ton of
space and it was cheap so that's when
steve bought this building in 81
and then they turned it into a lofts and
then that kind of happened
around here
and yeah a lot of weird stuff man it's
crazy yeah
do you guys find it super weird that
ren's body is just lying flask who wants
to put it on
on i mean good on that i definitely
don't trust myself
i'm going to grab it
i'm going to take it no but i'm not just
like just hold it up i'm not going to
put the insides of that thing anywhere
near me like a little blanket has this
uh
so weirdly he has a chest piece
so heavy though give us some sound he
has a rubber chest piece that he's that
his character is wearing for season two
son of a dungeon and
it's it's very life like looking uh
but it's
well it's pretty gnarly it's really
concerning
man it's just it's it's the thing is
it's hot still it still has a warmth
from ren right which is kind of gross
wearing it all day yeah
yes skin suit
my skin suit
yeah so what else is going on around
here what do you guys been up to today i
haven't talked to you guys all day yeah
we're just uh cooling down from last
week's kind of mad dash yeah
stormtroopers mad dash i kind of don't
know what to do with myself what's the
video
uh
the one on corridor
got like two million views in two days
2.5 ish i think or something yeah like
that nice
just
pretty good that's great man that's
that's awesome that's
yeah it's it's nice when you actually
set out to make a viral video and then
it goes viral right it's always uh
i mean kind of two for two with the
batman thing too 2.5 all downhill from
here
last time
[Laughter]
oh dang heck yes well that's awesome we
still got it guys still got it
did it get rebooted enough yet is it
like on twitter and
i actually haven't seen anything i
haven't seen like naturally yeah in a
couple weeks somebody will take it and
yeah i saw someone posted a still in the
star wars subreddit of darth vader
standing in the bloody rubber bodies but
they linked to the video which was cool
oh cool okay um that's good yeah it was
funny compared to the batman video like
i feel like the batman video was way
bigger on social media and stuff yeah on
youtube this video is popped off yeah
interesting the way that works it is
yeah there's like predictability to it
yeah like a viral video doesn't always
translate to like
a lot of views on your youtube channel
right you know
they're not like synonymous always
totally especially when it gets free
booted and stolen from you yeah yeah
yeah i have no idea how many
video views have been
stolen probably over half
probably yeah so we have
this isn't a brag this is just like i'm
just trying to give comparisons here we
have
2.5 or so billion
video views
i think
and one point on the quarter question
crew
one point two days so that's uh three
billion measly so i think you could
honestly say that there's probably
close to a billion views that haven't
been monetized yeah
it's crazy man billions stolen views
billions and billions of stuff one
billion stolen like mcdonald's
yeah it's a weird space because a lot of
times you know we're like did we steal
star wars
to get those views yeah
the yeah is no it's a parody and it's
well within the realm of parody and fair
use
um but
at the same time you know
yeah i guess if you are uh piggybacking
on other ips it's piggy that's
definitely the coattails
back on our piggyback but they're not
the people that are reposting it aren't
modifying it in any way yeah or any
creative yeah you know change to it
because which is there's a rip in it
right yeah that's not the same
storyblocks
storyblocks
is the sponsor today's episode once
again guys welcome back to this section
of the podcast i hope you're enjoying
this episode so far and i gotta take a
moment to tell you about storybox why
because well they make this show
possible and it's a phenomenal tool that
we use here every day come on you know
this when i was a young man i was asked
to make a video and i got all my footage
and i put it in my timeline which was
arduous enough mind you this is one of
my first experiences and then i realized
i needed stock assets and i had no place
whatsoever to go to for all my stock
asset needs there wasn't just an
abundance of beauty on story blocks like
there is today there wasn't an abundance
of high quality 4k b-roll motion
graphics after effects templates images
audio and more no i couldn't just with
the click of a mouse go to a website
that had unlimited all-access plans for
me to download royalty-free as much as i
needed from that site for whatever
purposes i was doing artistically no
that didn't exist it was a dark and
desolate time and then one person came
along and said what if there was a stock
asset website that that made it easier
that was your friend in the video
creation process and said hey you know
what you look like you could use some
help and came in with that loving
helping hand reassurance confidence and
all of a sudden the ideas were flowing
again the magic was happening once more
i wasn't limited necessarily by what i
could film it was it was all just about
what i could create in my mind i was
free at last and it was beautiful
and it still is beautiful because we use
storybox every day here at corridor
digital so if you guys are interested in
getting a stock asset source consider
story blocks they're phenomenal they
have high quality 4k b-roll and a ton
ton more they have a virtually unlimited
library so every time you go on there
there's gonna be something new for you
if you're interested in getting started
for yourself uh head on over to
storyblocks.comcast
or click the link in the description
below that's pretty easy nick maybe you
can put in some um like mountains here
or something like you know yeah yeah
like appalachian yeah
[Music]
that's it now back to the episode
the uh
one thing we were talking about with
niko yesterday is i didn't realize how
close the quarter channel was to that
diamond playbook
um
yeah it is pretty close it's like nine
point four seven yeah mm-hmm
i just checked it yesterday
popping up yeah no um
that's a big deal
i think
in like within the year within a year
from now
yeah yeah it's a put it on the wall oh
yeah it was kind it was cool
and then what we can all go home
do they have do they have one at like 50
and 100 i don't think so don't they have
one like didn't pewdiepie get like a
freaking like you got like a ruby didn't
it oh a ruby one oh yeah you get some
kind of ruby what's the highest it's
like made of the one true cross yeah
yeah it's like the holy grail really yes
so that's a thing and in catholic
cathedrals they say that the altar has
to have a piece to be truly a cathedral
that altar has to have a piece of the
true cross
in it being the true cross being the
cross that jesus actually died on okay
how many true crosses are there oh as
many as they could hand out
that's up to some debate you kind of
just throw a piece of old wood on a wall
and be like i don't know if anyone quite
knows what happened
i mean the holy land was the biggest
tourist destination for like all of our
history yeah lady throughout antiquity
the middle ages that was the place that
you back that's why they had crusades
because they were trying to get all that
visitors tourist money totally i mean
the crusades were just an armed pillar
disneyland dude when you said holy land
i'm from florida there's a holy land in
orlando it's called holy and that's what
you're talking about they just made it
by the way it's out of business now
because no one went to it but it was
just like this amusement park that just
like
it was a jesus amusement park was it
like was it like jerusalem or what i
mean they kind of tried to make a little
the tiny jerusalem kind of i heard that
somebody built a noah's ark in tennessee
they did yeah yeah whoa
to spec based on just an absurd amount
of money based on what it says in
genesis or i guess is that genesis or is
that exodus i think it's genesis
i've read the whole bible has anyone
done the math on like how many animals
out of it oh yeah yeah um i i don't know
they converted the measurements because
you know it's like old users yeah yeah
terms
totally yeah
well
you learned something new every day man
i didn't know that we had specs for an
arc but i'm glad all right so rip
rip okay
get into what's wrong sam always says
rip rip right and then like you lock
your keys in your car and somebody says
rip
yeah well so there was this guy i told
this about like r.i.p r.i.p rest in
peace okay so there was this guy
he was a soldier
uh he was a texas ranger he was a
confederate general he was uh he was all
these things uh he spotted the
mexican-american war um his name was
john salmon ford and at the end of his
um
battle
reports
when he listed the death count he used
to put rest in peace
he'd put all the names and send it to
command and then put rest in peace
and then
eventually he he was sending so many of
these
that he just changed it to rip
and then
his soldiers started calling him rip
ford or yeah
[Music]
somehow that ended up on halloween
decorations all across the globe yeah
that's that's fascinating actually i
feel like there's probably so many
movies that like take place before that
time where you see like a gravestone it
says like r.i.p or something i mean it
may have been using it may have been
used in use before that but
as far as i know it didn't it was
invented r.i.p
well popularized the term
it's so iconic
throughout history
people die throughout history and riff
has been used
death is kind of taken for granted the
fighting man it's all around us dude
like it's
it's like what wait did you say death no
like yeah like thinking about his
ah we have it so good oh yeah totally
like i watched dunkirk last night and
the whole time i was just like like
oh my god i know like i was watching
world war ii footage at lunch today and
i was just like man i'm sitting here
playing and playing this effing
playing in this fictional world
in front of this green screen like oh i
gotta rent a donkey
yeah it's like
dude
yeah yeah no we have it great that's why
i like history i've said this before but
it's just
learning about history and like
contextualizing our lives now yes can
almost cure my depression yes yeah no
seriously it makes it trivializes all of
our worries right um and it's you know
you gotta you gotta listen to yourself
but still totally it's important to zoom
out a little bit yeah yeah yeah we've
got like
yeah i mean it's just it's all
perspective i mean so many people were
like oh my god like everything's going
to hell and it's like man we are living
in kind of the best time ever right in
history like yeah we in a lot of ways
yeah so can you imagine living in the
northman times
like just walking around your shirt off
yeah
that's the only way you can operate your
village or whatever you can hang around
the like bombs
and just dude yeah the brutalities man
yeah we could do that yeah we should do
the brutalities of
we have a case of shelled pistachios
on the table right there they're in this
little k they come in this little
pre-packaged you know like plastic box
and you pull the thing open and you open
it up and there's
roasted
salted and shelled the pistachios that
you can just grab by the handful and
just
the food of kings meanwhile just a few
generations ago they were getting
literally shelled yeah yeah yeah right
yeah i feel i do feel bad for the guys
who have to sit there and you know
eat the pistachios and shell them and
then they don't get to eat them yeah
because i hear that's how they do it
what eat the pistachios and then they
don't eat them if you get a pistachio
and you have to break it open to get the
to get the seed inside
but now they're they sell them without
the shell you gotta spit them back so
how do you think they get them on
shelves dude they have an army of people
definitely do it that way yeah like that
coffee that that animal has to eat and
then poop out oh yeah yeah yeah
is that a thing yeah people do that
yeah poop coffee oh yeah it's it's
like the
[Music]
some of the rarest most sought after
coffee in the world is is digested
coffee because it literally does a
chemical process to the beans
and apparently it's really good i'd be
down to try i'm going to talk about
anybody
head over to corridor digital we're on
google that's a crew cuts right there
i'll drink it i will not be drinking
christian would do coffee dude oh you
did yeah christian did it
is it worth it
worth the poop
it was great what do you mean it's great
ollie
i'm sorry but like just walking around
here in l.a there's probably poo
particles in the air it's probably less
poop in the coffee than we covered in
the coffee you want to know how
expensive it is sausage is enough for me
they already have to take the intestine
and then bleach it and then that's what
the sausage casing is yeah totally do
you okay how's that in some coffee
price per pound is about a hundred to
six hundred dollars a
that's like pound
prices during the civil war
yeah yeah that poop juice well i mean
someone has to like collect it from the
from the little monkey toilet or the
little cat
so just let's just paint a full picture
here so what you're telling me is
somebody goes out and finds a specific
bean and they're like it's the arabica
strain of such and such and then they go
and they do they roast it first
they roast it first
and then they feed it to an animal what
animal an ox
i think i think it's like a cat
it's a cat yeah it's a cherry bean so
you cherry so and then poops out the
seeds which are the bees yeah it
consists of partially digested coffee
cherries oh they give them the full
chairs defecated by the asians
i think it's pronounced
c-i-v-e-t oh serve it
is that a cat i don't know what is the
service it's time to google some more
stuff yeah it's it's like a little puma
looking yeah but
it's a wild cat poop coffee yeah wild
cat they make something
then okay so then who
what is the processing for getting the
coffee once it's been defecated exhibit
just don't reach your head just reach in
and you just reach those beats
and then watch them do they roast it
after
yo it looks like a raccoon slash
i like that that's so cool dude check
this out oh that's cool this is a crazy
looking animal anyone raccoon folks at
home google a civet
it's like a raccoon hyena cat it's on
its first look at that thing that's so
cool that's an insane looking animal yes
it's a white like it looks like a what
or else we go oh crust of the human
condition my friend yeah i mean hey
we're dependent on each other for
survival and in exchange we trade
value to each other why is it just this
weird animal that can produce the best
poop coffee
it just likes it likes what happens what
happens to this poor cat when it's like
high on caffeine just i don't think it
would be
absorbs any of them probably not because
the fruit doesn't have yeah it's only
the inside of the bean or the the cherry
there's still caffeine in the in the
bean though really well it's in the
chicken the cherry the fruit the
whatever it's not in the husk it's the
fruit caffeine's not in the house that's
what i'm saying so it eats the husk
gives us the bean win
that's that's job
baby you get fed on the job you get
meals taken care of dude
you know you have a purpose how many
cats do you think like an operation has
that's
[Laughter]
how do you pronounce the
thing that's the vet the you should
think it is you should cut into some of
your phone footage from that trip over
this podcast we know a lot about this
pop it on top
yeah we're the authorities i'm super
down to try that well if it's monday
morning and you're listening to this
driving to work i hope that your coffee
is is uh i hope you didn't pay 600 a
pound for your coffee yeah yeah what
kind of rich [ __ ] thing is that
i mean it probably started as like a
normal person thing and now it's a rich
[ __ ] thing yeah well that's what
always happens like vox did an article
right yeah and now it's yeah
because it has a limited supply it
immediately gets bought totally delicacy
like eating snails what are we talking
about
yeah you call it escargo and now it's
expensive yeah snail sticks snail sticks
like bone marrow we were just talking
about gator we might want to get we
actually might order some gatorade if
you want to get in on that
gator it's not very good really i'm a
fan
but not in like a good way it's kind of
like the calamari of the swamp
a little bit of a chewiness to it when i
had it well i'd be willing to try it
again
oh you did yeah fried fried dinner uh no
it was uh when christian i went when did
you go to papadopoulos it was in the
airport
in florida yeah yeah yeah i didn't know
that by the way and then we had fried
gator we were waiting and i want to try
some cakes i only had it when we did our
texas trip papadopoulos is the [ __ ] it
is
i mean we did get a puppet but we
earlier we were just thinking about like
what the name of the place was
exploding for a second and then we
looked at each other and then both
immediately
[Music]
i've been trying to take my
mother-in-law there for her birthday
which was on march 16th
but you you it's like that hard to get
what well i haven't like made a
reservation and we've been you know kind
of casual about it because we got the
small kids and so we have to find the
right time to go gotcha but
papa go dude one does not simply just go
to papadopoulos
you don't just go no you don't just show
up
not unless you want to wait an hour and
a half yeah
you gotta have you have to be special
poignant about it
yes yeah
yeah it's a good place man i would try
gator that sounds good i mean it's
twenty four dollars a pound you can
order it online i have the link right on
my phone it's better than the poop
coffee yeah cheaper than the coffee
that's a deal gator you want poop coffee
let's do it i'm all about perspective
let's do a whole meal
your bowels will be clean after that oh
yes
hey we're thinking about a spice cast
here yes yes and that's something that i
i just want to throw it out there again
that i would love yeah to participate
yes in something where we just eat the
spiciest no we're thinking like how long
fried chicken spiciest flavor next week
on the i'm so down okay and then maybe
play like spy fall or something yes yeah
spice fall spicy balls
it's spicy let's do it next week i think
that would be fun son of a dungeon will
still be filming yeah we'll come back
we'll do an after hours spice fall spice
spice cast yeah spice casserole spice
fall is it what is it this is spice cast
or spice fall spicy spice fall spice
how spicy should we get on the spice
guest
pepper preference let us know yeah i
think we should ruin our lives for a
night yeah like i'll go howling yeah
yeah yeah no i'm gonna go home i don't
want to give you the glove to eat oh you
could bring the bomb dude
christian's birthday party like four
years ago we did the whole gauntlet of
the uh hot ones
hot sauces on wings
and
it got rough it's a great show man
people in the bathroom lined up like
waiting
brutal man we were throwing around uh
just random crew video ideas and we were
like
just a stu super dumb one that we came
up with was just based on all the
ragdoll stuff and like lighting chewie
on fire in the star wars video you just
have hot one guess but they actually
just spontaneously come back
so that's yes so that's sorry i spit all
over the microphone
that's what i was talking about the
other day with like parodying things
that people already know yeah i feel
like we could do it we could totally
dude that bike to turn parkour videos
dummy parkour there's a lot of stuff you
can do with ragdolls man i love
ragdoll parkour that's like i know i
really it's just let's do it parkour is
still popular it's always going to be
popular dude particularly but it's not
definitely
still making stuff
but it's not like how it was like the
office made it funny and then it's like
but that was a long time ago and i don't
know if it's like it's not like as
relevant of a joke you know jessie
leflare that maybe that's how you start
he's gonna show up in the comments yeah
like you will you [ __ ] jump off your
head and you're off jesse
you're gonna gain her off your face if
he hears you saying that
off your face after he poops out a
coffee
literally brew that [ __ ]
you gotta brew that [ __ ] baby yeah that
that's a that's a good can of worms open
like parodies of other youtube content
yeah i feel like you could get weird one
with a mukbang that goes wrong
yeah oh how weird is youtube mukbangs
are strange man what kind of people sit
there and watch like asian girls eat
food but see the thing is jake like i
thought the same creepy it is creepy and
weird but like i i started watching one
of those videos just to start making fun
of it yeah and then i couldn't stop
watching it and i don't know why you
learned you learned to watch mukbang
ironically yeah but that was my
shirtless with crab dripping
i got really hungry and had to order the
[ __ ] that they were yeah
exactly i don't know man
yeah that's a weird route for me dude
hey man weird dog like those weird um
superhero videos that are for kids that
have no have no words
and they're all just like oh yeah that's
weird so it's like creepy weird
like predatory it's so predatory yeah i
think yeah i was telling my friends
about that and he had no problem with it
he was like
and i was like
but dude people put this on
for their kids and they don't even like
they glance at it they don't even know
how weird it is and how regulatory it is
it's like weirdly sexual yes gross
yeah and they're like adults and these
are weird right
just it's just wrong man it's like i
don't know what else to say about it
it's just it's just wrong just go home
turn these videos off do your kids watch
any youtube jake
yeah they watch uh like you know like
the kids songs and stuff but we know
what it is and we know what channels
it's from sure yeah we also don't just
like turn it on and hand it to them yeah
that's dude honestly ipad babies okay so
i'm gonna go on a quick tangent yeah
yeah yeah
after hours let's go after that so
my
wendy's
um
got family down in mexico and they they
have
uh there's a they have a nine-year-old
down there and
she's on the tablet like 24 hours a day
dude like when she's not sleeping like
she's on the tablet and they're like
well look like they and they so they
consider it like a learning device and
they're like look like
look she learned how to like speak
english because she was watching so many
videos in english like she learned
english
but all of the all kids are supposed to
be
like playing with things and playing
with their hands and like messing with
stuff and like it's frustrating as a
parent when like your two-year-old walks
up and grabs like a bin full of
something and dumps it out on the floor
but that's like what they're supposed to
be doing they're supposed to be doing
that so they can get into the world and
like get you know not injured but like
you know like bruise your knee and
scrape your elbow and like
like fall over and touch the thing
that's hot and like
learn
how to like
be cautious and wise in the world around
you like ultimately we're hunters and
we're like hunter-gatherers that's like
still our core and if you
and if you take away that discovery and
we're problem solvers we have human
beings like if we lived in a perfect you
know utopia
we would ultimately
just find another problem that's what we
do you could give us everything you give
us everything but ultimately we'd be
like oh well
that picture frame is slightly at an
angle it's not perfectly straight my
coffee wasn't pulled from right now and
that's why we work that's why we're
going to act in a perfect enough
universe there is some alternate
universe out there where like there is a
civil war going on because a picture
frame is slightly off-tilt
like that but we would just find another
thing to fight about and another problem
to solve and that that's just who we are
we just do that because that's how we've
survived that's part of our survival
instinct and when you give a kid
like
just the tap
look they have their they have their
purpose i'm not trying to be a luddite
here but
when when they are
the instinct of discovery
is happening and the satisfaction of
problem solving is happening because
they're watching somebody else do
something like watch a video game and
that's the only source of where they're
getting that
that is not good because when you take
that away they don't know what to do
they just go
what do i do
i need the thing back like give me the
thing
give me the thing that gives me that
yeah
it's like you definitely need to have
that like exploratory kind of real world
stuff and definitely like with playing
with other kids and just
totally not being glued to this i just
have a skateboard
that is part of our survival yeah the
ipad's on the other side of the door
yeah yeah it's an escape room and you
got to get out there honestly that would
be fine because at least they'd have to
figure it out
yeah man i can't imagine uh raising the
kid in the age of
like
devices jake you ever uh
wonder when your kids are first gonna
come to you and show you yourself on
youtube oh they yeah they already have
done that yeah yeah they're they'll be
like dad what's their favorite brand
it's not expressvpn sorry express yeah
jj and eliza fought that one out and
squarespace came out on top first base
okay wow yeah their first love i i
that's kind of a proud dad moment right
there it was yeah and i said what do you
do and eliza said get 10 off your first
going to make great purchase
with these award-winning templates hell
yeah yeah dude
that's awesome yeah yeah do you like i
don't know if this is way too inside
baseball or but just as a father do you
ever like think like
i want them to keep going with the old
family business like
like i don't know is is that if that's
too personal of a question no that's
fine that's
how could you ask personally i'm sorry
after actually asking me a question
whether i want my children to do when
they grow up how dare you fenner
no like uh eliza's shown interest in
cameras and in videos um
and uh
she says she wants to be an astronaut
but it's only because they get to wear
cool costumes yeah that's what you're
wearing right now man i know yeah
i wanted to be a train conductor but
that doesn't pan out and look
everybody's like you're discouraging
your daughter from not wanting to be an
astronaut like look no i just know that
the math math is not her strong suit jj
he's got the math thing he's like i need
to know why this works and why two plus
two equals four and if i take these away
then it equals three and like he's very
and that's what you need to be if you're
going to be
in outer space and a super fragile
machine
eliza's like i just want to ride my bike
and sing and like take pictures and like
draw poems or draw draw photos and write
poems and like that's just how she is
that's just her personality yeah so i
think she's she's more artistically
inclined
and so
if she shows encouragement but honestly
dude i just want them to be happy like i
don't i don't care if they work at a gas
station honestly as long as they feel
like that's the place that they're
supposed to be
it's kind of it's kind of crazy that
there's like at least there's probably
one thing that your kids are doing that
they're gonna grow up to do and be
really good at that they're good at
right now but you don't know what that
thing is really yeah but like for
example like because i um
uh on mother's day i went over to my
mom's place and we watched some old
videos
and
me as a kid i wanted to be behind that
camera that they were filming with and
looking at what was happening yeah on
the camera all the time yeah that was
you saw like constantly that was the
thing i could be like or something
can i see it yeah you know and it's all
the thing in the front of the camera but
i don't know that that's gonna end up
being the thing that i do right but you
know there's like little stuff that they
take interest in
it's so it's so fascinating
i get to see i'm the only one that sees
it
my camera yeah i swore that day i would
never not be able to see it again
like when you were younger did you kind
of know like hey i when i saw a camera
or when i saw a video that i knew that's
what i wanted to do yeah i i feel super
lucky because i was kind of from a young
age i remember my sister coming home and
we got photoshop on our computer
i think probably pirated she was a few
years older and she's like check this
out it's like ms paint but better
and that's when i was like first i
remember
i can't remember which version of
photoshop it was but it was like you
could do like a rainbow like filter
thing that would just like make a beam
and i was like oh my god you can make
like little magic like beams yeah
and then i was like ever since then i
was like oh sweet photoshop awesome oh
that's sweet yeah it's just like i
remember i have one of my earliest
memories is being a little kid in ms
paint and being like i'm gonna draw a
photo of my dad for father's day oh
that's and there was like only three
undo's at the time oh yeah he used like
the spray paint thing did he had a beard
at the time to give his stubble but then
it just made it look like he had poop
all over his face
i tried to undo it and i couldn't and
then i just ended up crying and i was
all upset oh man but he still said it
looked great oh of course but that was
that's one of my earliest memories of
probably making something on a computer
and i don't know if i was like
like three or four or something like
well yeah that's i don't know i guess
that was my earliest like
content creator memory you remember
being three or four and doing that
i remember
i think i would have been four it's like
a super visceral memory for me because i
was so upset that you couldn't
understand
yeah
i see you they gotta fix did you have
that nick did you like know like early
you wanted to be a creator i'm in a
weird situation because i grew up in
like a long line of artists like my dad
say the family is like family biz
honestly
his mom was an artist her dad was a
pretty damn established painter who was
also the cousin of george gershwin so
like it's like a whole thing yeah so if
i had become a lawyer they would have
been like what the [ __ ] is this kid
doing
they would have disowned me yeah but
also hilarious i grew up you know seeing
my dad drawing yeah he did so i used to
draw and
i used to i mean yeah i got that camera
when i was 10 and uh started making
movies my 10th birthday party i invited
all my friends and
i spent a month
making swords so they'd all have
something and then i shot a big battle
scene and like wow
yeah dude i had like 20 kids
and i was like all right you guys are
the orcs you guys are the humans and
we're gonna [ __ ] battle and then i
was just like directing them and like
yeah so cool it was just like honestly
it was like hey dad can you just shoot
and we're just gonna play
yeah which is fun you know so like i
always wanted you weren't you weren't
like okay guys back you you guys back in
five all right we need you over here for
the medium um and we're gonna flip
around
yeah i mean it didn't quite get that
technical i haven't figured it out i was
just like a camera is somewhere in here
yeah yeah but
so yeah i mean i definitely had that
like
it's nice to
we're very lucky for
having that though and knowing kind of
from a young age what we want to do yeah
definitely yeah it's it's easy to take
that for granted for sure yeah i never
had that
yeah yeah you want a guy like a lawyer
right like no no
no what was pre-lawyer
uh
well depending on how far back you go i
remember the first thing i ever wanted
to be was a professional baseball player
oh hell yeah and i was like yo baseball
is the coolest thing right
yeah
mine was professional hockey player yeah
yes and then
but i was the youngest of
four
and i had two older brothers and i was
always like
in their circle with their the kids
their age and my old my closest brother
was only two years older than me so he
wasn't that much older but
i think
that's kind of
how i fell into doing what i was doing
because i was always like seeing what
other people were doing and then being
like oh hey if you're doing that i could
do this
but i never had that like thing where i
was like i need to do this
thing in particular
i was always like figuring out a way to
like add something or like you know
contribute in but i was never the one
making the rules
there's still that creative like or like
that well it's definitely creative yeah
yeah it's definitely creative um
but it wasn't like
you know where i picked up a camera or i
like drew a picture or and i and i knew
so
you went to the same high school that
sam and nico went to right yes okay so
yeah they were like
xbox party oh
[Music]
you do that it's like we gotta have a
lan party or something we shouldn't do
that if you guys play mario kart
upstairs i would play oh a mario kart
situation what about what about the
original halo dude i would play that too
yeah
yeah you uh yeah
halo halo
i assume you can you can play it on
steam now on what halo yeah yeah yeah i
mean yeah the master chief collection
yeah so you should definitely do that so
i met nico
when
him and i were on the cross country ski
team okay i've told this story before
but they haven't told it in a while
and then uh nico and i knew this
mutually had this friend named david
lovett who wrote who co-wrote top 10
games you can play in your head by
yourself
and then david and i were in like a
youth group and then david would always
have xbox parties at his house it was
like the place where you went to lan
party
and then one night we were there and
there was this like
sassy like kid
who was just kicking my ass
in halo and i hate i i didn't hate him
but i was like this [ __ ] guy
i was like this [ __ ] guy it could get
heated yeah it could get heated and
because sam didn't say very much you
know and
like you [ __ ] little [ __ ]
he was just smoking me the whole time
um was he tea bagging too just i don't
know if he was tea bagging i don't
[Laughter]
yeah
um yeah and then uh
that was when i met sam
like tenth grade
that's where halo rivals yeah
did did you all like make movies and
stuff so sam and nico used to and then
they would every friday morning the
school had like uh
the av club or whatever it was like got
to like show their work
and so like every now and then
sam they might recollect this more
clearly but every now and then they'd
have like their videos that they would
shoot
and then they get played in front of the
whole school
for 15 minutes or five minutes or
whatever it was
same actually yeah same yeah yeah dude
yeah we we had a uh was it like a
morning announcements thing yes it was
part of morning announcements yeah so i
was i was a part of a thing called titan
tv which was the titans or the freaking
we were olympia high school so you know
greek stuff yeah yeah
the greek business but we had like a
whole like proper
morning announcements news show
um where we'd be we were anchors and
we'd also like make content yeah and the
content that we made was they were like
short films and stuff and like funny
skits yeah and like we over produced the
hell out of those things because we were
up way above most other people in high
school so me and my buddy my buddy had a
camera because a camera was a rare thing
back then especially a digital camera
yeah we had this whole we would shoot
these videos where we would just put the
camera static
and it was a it was a car it was a
carnival
and we had characters for every
and it was like people trying to get
into the carnival and we had all the
carnie characters who were like part of
the cast
and this was like an ongoing video
production that never got distributed
but
that was my first foyer into
video creating that's awesome
yeah man i think the best part was just
watching the footage with your friends
yeah that was that was the whole
let's just relive these funny moments
yeah i we threw it around a couple weeks
ago i love the idea of going back and
like remastering some of your totally
probably the oldest videos you could get
like go through like ai upscaling them
like making them look as good as we
possibly can so it's like you fighting
in your yard but like
if that footage exists like that would
be so fun it actually does oh yeah so oh
no
i think a lot of us have stuff yeah yeah
i i think we could probably source a lot
of footage yeah yeah um definitely
because
so for my 11th birthday party
thank you so much
you laughed but then i spent that next
year making
better costumes and actually writing a
little script and then i found a
location what and we went out and
re-shot the whole thing but like
properly and this time i had two
cameramen
oh my dad's my friends
i actually found that footage because we
like i had the dv tapes and like
in like 2011 i had them digitized okay
and then so now i have the footage
somewhere it's on like when my archive
drives but i started editing it and i'm
just like dude this is i can't do it
okay
one of the goals that we've wanted to do
for a while was uh it's we we refer to
this concept as the pimp my video
concept but yes what we really need
is like a 10 to 13 year old like video
you know it's like hey i shot this video
with my friends
and i cut it together
and then they give it to us with the raw
footage and then we we do the corridor
a thing on it yeah yeah it's it's been
very hard to find that i know it's a
very niche thing
because
the jank runs too deep often like yeah
it's often hard to
uh fix something that at its core
doesn't have the building blocks to be
fixed yeah like
i mean maybe now that we have a more
developed vfx team we could like
but a lot of times
i feel like that's the challenge isn't
it like let's make let's like just
tackle something that we're like i don't
know how to fix this yeah that's part of
the fun of the video a lot of times all
you need are inserts yeah yeah we can
shoot other stuff additionally we got
deep fakes now oh totally we got i mean
yeah projection mapping with full cg
environments based on the ones that they
actually right because often what
happens like a lot of submissions we get
is just like
a wide shot of all the action and that's
all they have like and that's totally
we've all been there yeah but it's hard
to like turn that into more uh unless
you build out
a lot of stuff yeah and maybe that's
where uh your your talents could come in
that'd be it would be so fun like i even
just doing a challenge of like even if
you just recreate like my first vfx shot
recreated yeah it would be like a very
like
i don't know i feel like very
heartwarming yeah it'd be fun like
exploration too under like how
how you can
basically like comparing what you did
then versus what you can do now yeah is
like i think that that would hit really
hard yeah and not even like personal
skills just technology-wise sure oh yeah
the advancements yeah yeah we could yeah
that would be really interesting to do
it's like
take a couple people
maybe a moment from one of the shorts it
doesn't have to be a whole thing
and then just like okay i got my
resources my knowledge now let me
completely remake it yeah
yeah yeah so we're gonna remake nick's
11th birthday
dude we don't have enough production
value dude
you can't even refreeze helicopters no
i'm just kidding
no i think we could but
there might be some other ones that
would be even better yeah i feel like
it's a better story if it's a kid that's
still a kid yes definitely that that was
actually a really fun part of the
stormtroopers thing was uh kind of like
paying homage to like sam and nico's i
think it's called like the alive armor
or something they're having them in like
the x-wing costumes i was like
i was i was like that was pretty cool
and it wasn't it wasn't lost on the
audience yeah which i was really happy
about
so maybe that's one we'd remake the
whole thing totally i mean oh my god
for sure you got the project files
already i know i feel like we could like
do it without like it wouldn't be that
crazy recreate the alpine armor the 4k
remaster no star
wars is all about those remasters too
the look on sam's face i can see it now
she'd be like
yeah but then look after he sees it
would be yeah come on that twinkle in
his eyes
dude he was so happy to put on that
x-wing costume i'm sure you're talking
about the tiny man
dude the tiny man joke is my favorite
thing in that entire video that was so
much
there was so much more behind the scenes
i know that yeah with him talking like
of that at the end of the video like you
should drop it on instagram yeah we
could probably do that because there's
some funny ones it just we didn't
literally didn't have time to keep that
in mind yeah yeah drop it up and throw
it on instagram that's perfect i just
shout out casey and kevin yes they
killed it also
they're geniuses so i talked to them
and i was like all right so
because i didn't know how long the thing
was gonna be
and uh
they were like i was like uh yeah so
it's gonna be about 90 seconds like
similar to the batman thing
and then kevin's like uh this is six
minutes of full recreated sound design
[Music]
oh um right we'll we'll talk about this
yeah yeah
yeah but it dude it came through
yeah i mean like
we were saying like three days before it
came out we kind of did a like rough cut
review and we're like oh no this is
terrible
there was definitely a moment
where i think me you and jordan were all
kind of like
oh no what have we done
and then but
i feel like in those last two days it
really it came together and totally like
casey and kevin's such a huge part of
that man yeah people don't notice how
important the the audio aspect is yeah
people just think it's all visual it's
visual effects it's the shots it's the
frame it's the acting like no
it is called audio visual work for a
reason yeah it's like you get the
project to 90
right yeah and you're like okay we've
we've like reached the peak of this
mountain but there's the ten percent is
a whole other mountain yeah decline
totally you know yeah that's the same
height maybe higher right right because
it's that that ten percent of polish
that really makes the video work that's
a good analogy it takes you just as long
to hike that yep as it takes you to hike
the first 90 percent yeah
yeah i can relate with that deeply so
don't be discouraged
if you're out there yeah man
yeah if you've got a video that's at 90
and you're like this just isn't working
don't worry there's a don't worry
another mountain there's a ball you
gotta climb a lot and you don't even
know where it is because maybe you
haven't been to that mountain yet
exactly you don't even know where you're
like there's another mountain and
and yes there is but as long as you keep
wandering you find the trail of events
wonderful it's true you might die in the
woods somewhere but don't worry
you'll get regenerated and you'll start
back at the base of the first map yeah
don't be afraid to ask for help folks
other people know what that means
cut to kitten meme
but really dude
crater burnout's real
yeah man
follow the kitten
follow that
follow the kitten
hey what's with all these um
creators in boxing now
yeah should we do we just had creator
class yeah yeah creator clash yeah
did did logan paul start this or i
assume so oh wait no um uh uh what's his
name oh jesus idubbbz dude yeah idubbbz
no i know but i'm not talking about like
this specific instance oh you're talking
about the culture of create of you of
youtubers
yeah
he won his fight i don't know if he
fought another one after that but he won
his first fight i think it's going to be
therapeutic for our industry because
youtubers we already fight in drama you
know right that's why philip defranco
has a job right because he reports on
all the youtuber drama and fills us in
right fills me in all the time and
filled in yeah but like
now that they can just box each other
and really fight is he going to be out
of a job
true i don't know i don't know man
there's not going to be any more
confidence
there's something terribly pathetic and
also very entertaining about the whole
thing yeah
yeah it was like very entertaining i was
laughing i was having a great time it
was it was it was well produced i should
check it out it was not produced but
it's i'm guessing on youtube you you
compare that to like floyd mayweather
fight and you're just like
does anyone know that there's people who
are better at boxing
but that's not the point i'm not trying
to be salty about it but
it was it was weird to watch it was like
hey do you want to watch
hey okay i have dodgers tickets or we
can go to a t-ball game what do you want
to do yeah and it's like well
maybe you want to go to the t-ball game
but
it's also it's the personalities and
it's the like i know this guy and i know
i've seen him in all i've seen him in
this context but i haven't seen him in
this context that's what it is it's like
would you rather go to your buddies
t-ball game or go see the dodgers right
it's like your your buddy it's these
people you feel like you have this
parasocial relationship with yeah so
you're like oh yeah i'm rooting for them
like no and that's what makes it
entertaining for sure and that and i was
entertained by that as well what if we
do our own version of boxing but it's
like mocap boxing
no cat box we made our own creative we
made our own
can be any wacky character we want
you can pick any
character from internet culture yeah
george lucas versus mickey mouse yeah
it's any anything you want yeah anything
in battle and we'll skin you as that
character
real life smash bros i'm gonna be
justine
i call phil defranco yeah i got you
ray william johnson oh man
from the
grave from the dead dude rise out of a
coffin
dude it's weird sometimes i don't know
if there's any
i do miss sparring in the studio with
you guys like swords and like big bubble
things tell me we gotta get there we
gotta get the rest of this building and
then then we could have another gym we
could have a fighting engine we can have
a fighting gym yeah that's what we
really need is a fighting [ __ ] i think
we did what i was thinking
absolutely yeah i mean
hello
do you think we should get a fighting
job and then there'll be a smash corner
and then real fighting all in the
fighting gym yeah yes jake and i can
just fight for real well you guys yeah
each other yeah smash brothers yeah
yeah we take our passive aggressiveness
and turn it into a boxing match i mean
my storage skills have decreased over
the whole years of course i've been
training yeah i mean
i i used to be you know he's not even
gonna need to do no training he ain't
even gonna need you know training
all one word
that no i don't know if people know this
story we've talked about it before have
we yeah we were filming we were filming
uh anime fidget spinners
and we were in this alley and it's like
2 a.m 3 a.m 4 a.m we're getting loopy
we've been filming all night
i get this call and i mute it because
we're more on set and then i check the
voicemail and it's like
people at a party
somewhere else who called the wrong
number
and it's like at a party and they don't
know and it's like a butt dial and it
left a voicemail message on my phone and
it's like all you hear is this
like loud very loud raucous party going
on and like people chanting and going
chug chug chug and then this one lady
goes she ain't even going to need to do
no training
[Music]
i remember that i think you played that
don't you say that
can you play it for the podcast yeah
i still want to get shirts that say it's
all apostrophes it says sheen it's all
one
sentence let me see if i can pull it up
it's so good dude oh my god it's so good
yeah
anime fidget spinners training that kind
of got us through the rest of the night
we were doing competitive oh you're just
spinning on set so okay so jake heard
this and played it for everyone yeah
yeah immediately sitting there like that
man
that's weird i have the voice recording
that's so awesome
oh man
are you i remember you brought it up in
texas do you have a hole in the bottom
of your shoe i hope not oh i know what
is that it's like screwed up man you
should have got all the besties it's for
the pumps i get i can pump it up oh
pumped up
all those other kids
do you think fidget spinners are going
to come back
no
no
i don't think so damn no maybe like
ironically in 10 years like
they're kind of fun hipsters will be
sitting at coffee shops yeah
that's good so weird trends like that
just like they they're they catch fire
yeah like crazy and then everyone's
doing it and then it's just like gone
it's like pokemon go yeah that was the
last maybe it was in an email
it was a pokemon go she was yeah i want
a fidget spinner that can like
like save all that energy you know like
so you could like charge your phone on a
fidget spinner yeah it could be cool and
never run out of battery wow kind of
awesome oh wait maybe it's on my phone
like on my actual phone files oh i need
to find this like in your voicemail
still from like eight years he didn't
even need no training
training see it took me a long time to
get that down i had to really work on it
how does it go exactly she is not
even going to need to do any training
one breath ready
[Laughter]
i love it man if i can't find it right
here i'll give up that's awesome
i wonder what they were doing at that
party that's what i wake up at night
yeah like what were they training for
what were they not
and what is she so proficient at yeah no
training i have a theory i have a theory
okay so one time
i was in this little town called tofino
it's a little surf town
west coast of vancouver island and there
just so happened to be a university
uh they had like a surf club there and
they had a bunch of kegs
and they were doing keg stands yeah
that's well that's what i thought and
this one girl goes up i figured and
she's like i've never done a cake stand
before and we're like okay cool lift her
up
and she's doing the keg stand for like
two minutes wow and we're like doesn't
she need to breathe like what is going
on and she comes down and she goes oh
yeah i free dive professionally whoa
so that's what this lady is training for
oh my god she doesn't mean you know
training she's because she's she's a
free diver she's a free driver in canada
okay that was her it was the same person
it could have been the same it was
probably that was probably the same
party what year was this oh my god wait
what year was that donald j what year
was it oh my god it would have been what
years and now 2022 it would have been
like 20 2018
that's when we are you
it truly was one of the most impressive
twenty-one i've ever seen
oh 2017. might have been 2017. i don't
know
i have a keg stance
all right
um are we done because i have a keg
stand story oh you have a cake oh god
matt
[Laughter]
all right so
literally
it's literally close it out man let's go
what did i miss so
i was in high school this is like senior
year of high school now i was a
christian boy up until high school and
then high school came around and i was
like oh beer is cool yeah so you know
kind of pivoted uh i went to a public
high school for the first time so you
know a lot of my friends there um got me
into like a party scene a little bit of
party stuff in like senior year so i
went to like one of my first bigger
parties that had a keg i've never seen a
keg
yeah but um
i was always really good at um
slamming water bottles
i don't know why it was a thing that i
was good at but i could impressively
like just down a bottle of water in like
a second so i saw the keg stand and
there was like a little list of like uh
record times like who had the best time
and it was like i think like 14 seconds
or something nothing is more like 17 18
year old than that it's like hey guys
let's drink and poisonous substance and
so you can do it the longest yeah as
fast as possible
for the longest yeah so i was thinking
in my head water beer same thing
my turn yeah so i get up to that keg and
they
pick me up pull me over and i start
slurping down that good beer juice yeah
and it goes to like 10 seconds 11
seconds there's a whole crowd around me
in this garage yeah they're all like
[ __ ] cheering me on at this point
yeah because they're like oh [ __ ] he's
gonna break the record of the night
right and then it goes to 14 15 16 17.
and so that at that point i was like oh
i just just blew past this easy they
turned me around and i'm like cheering
and as i open my mouth i projectile
vomit
and it's like it's literally as if i
became the keg
it was transferred
it came out of my mouth and got on like
people i i
i puked on people i puked all over the
garage and
and the rest of the night i was just
like i think i was just in a bathtub
because they didn't know what to do with
me that was like a bathtub
and i was just
that was my introduction to parties in
high school oh my god and and i've never
lived that down either i never went to a
party like that again actually because i
feel like there's a whole podcast worth
of like
adolescents
we can tell this
have been regulated to a bathtub
party before but yeah i'm not proud of
it i broke the record though
[ __ ] all them i did it i did it anyway
yeah uh well holy ladies and gentlemen
hopefully
you're making smarter decisions than
that
uh don't drink in high school ruins your
brain
um cells for you yeah be responsible
it's a real thing don't tell me what to
do
sorry i'll go to a high school and drink
okay i think that's i think that's hard
blink
oh my god what a perfect outro it is
you're not the boss of me
[Music]
it's all right to tell me
what you think about me
i won't try to argue
i'll hold it against you i know that
you're leaving you must have your
reasons
[Music]
it'll happen once again
you'll turn to a friend
someone understands
and sees through the promised land i
don't know if that is the real words but
it doesn't really matter because if
you're not still listening
if you're still
listening for watching everybody thanks
for being here thank you for enjoying
the after hours cast we appreciate you
and we love you thank you